welcome to Haris hobbies the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and dove into newest tech products so
today we're taking a look at if the 8700
K will actually be replaced by an
octa-core processor by Intel this year
in 2018 but before we delve into that
make sure to hit that subscribe button
if you guys would like to stay updated
with latest tech news related to gaming
and pcs so as you guys already know
there have been a lot of rumors that
Intel is going to be bringing out the
8800 K or the 97 4k which is going to be
an 8 core 16 thread processor in the
last quarter of this year this is simply
expected to be an extension of the
coffee-like platform however this new
chip will also require a new motherboard
on the z 390 platform because of the
extra power requirements of the 2 extra
cores and 4 extra threads however at the
same time there were very many rumors
about the new gtx 1100 series coming
from Nvidia and they're all suggesting
that in video is going to release them
before the end of 2018 however based on
the CEO of Nvidia Jensen Hong's recent
comments that may not be true anymore so
what is to say that the 8 core 16 thread
CPU from intohe won't end up in the same
cases invidious next generation of GPUs
what does this say that Intel will
release it in 2018 especially
considering how short period of time
that it has been since the 8750 a came
out well in my opinion intohe will come
out with the octa-core processor by the
end of this year because even though
Nvidia and Intel are big players in
their respective markets and they had
very many aspects are very similar their
current positions in their market are
quite different and this alteration in
market standing would lead to very many
changes in perception and ultimately
lead to a difference in the release of
the next generation of hardware from
both companies first let's take a look
at the differences between Nvidia and
intohe in their respective markets
Nvidia launched their 10 series graphics
cards over two years ago however even
today people are even willing to overpay
for them so as result it is clear that
Nvidia is dominating their mark in
performance however for Intel there's
story is not the same it dough has just
rushed their least after coffee like
CPUs after rising came out and they're
struggling to keep up there are still
two cores behind risin and many people
are switching over to rising and India
has been losing a lot of market share on
top of this Intel only dominates in the
gaming scene and risin is so much better
for productivity tasks and it still
exhales really well in gaming as well so
really risin is the better all-round
chip and so Intel is not doing very well
as it is evident Nvidia is already
dominating the market with their
performance and as a result they have no
reason to come out with the next
generation of GPUs however Intel is
struggling to keep up and are fiercely
competing with rising right now and as a
result so it would definitely make sense
for Intel to provide more performance in
an attempt to catch up with Rison next
up NVIDIA GPUs are just starting to hit
MSRP and there was selling really well
even overpriced
however the Intel i7 87 Rek can often be
found for less than MSRP but it's still
not selling as well because of the
insane competition put on Verizon and
the great value that it provides so as
we are talking about Rison and AMD
something else to keep in mind is that
Nvidia really has no competition right
now the rx 500 series was actually a
pretty good competition for the
mid-level cards like the GTX 1060 but
the problem is is that the rx 500 series
has been overpriced for over a year now
and the overpricing situation still
persists for rx 500 series so as a
result Nvidia really has no competition
and as for the mega series the Vega
series can barely compete with the
higher level of GTX cards so it really
doesn't matter for Nvidia the situation
with Intel and AMD is much more
different aim D offered a great value
with Rison and they offered even better
value with the rise in second generation
and because of this AMD has been taking
huge shares of market share away from
Intel and so as a result into has
competition to face while NVIDIA does
not as a result in toast limited
dominance in the cpu market limited
demand and fierce competition that they
had faced against Rison has all put into
at a much worse spot than in video and
because of these
during situations between Nvidia and
Intel in tell us much more likely than
follow through and actually release an
octa-core processor like expected even
though Nvidia may not actually release
the next generation of GPUs on top of
this Nvidia didn't have a roadmap as to
when the next generation of GPUs were
going to come out and as a result all
the rumors surrounding the gtx 1180 were
pretty much just speculation however
with intel on their roadmap they have
something called z through 90 that is
set to come out in the second half of
2018 overall there were very many rumors
about the gtx 1180 and the gtx 1100
series however with the recent comments
made by mr. Jensen wrong a lot of eager
gamers have been disappointed that they
may not be able to upgrade to the next
generation of GPUs before the end of
2018 now this raises the question well
intel do something similar and not
released octa-core processor like
everybody expects well in my opinion no
Intel will not do that because long
story short Nvidia doesn't have any
competition so they can do whatever they
want
while Intel does in the past intohe was
also like Nvidia and they would just
cruise through their cpu launches and
while a year and a half ago until may
not have even considered launching an
octa-core processor the mainstream
platform in the next five years due to
the presence of competition Intel is
obviously acting much differently which
can be seen in how they watch the launch
of coffee lake however now octa-core
processors are getting much more popular
due to Rison and AMD may even bring out
12 course or even 16 cores with their
next rise in three generation which is
also going on to seven animator process
so it really wouldn't make any sense for
Intel to so stick to the 40 nanometer
process and be offering a 6 core
processor as their mainstream flagship
so considering all that I think that it
is safe to assume that --into will
release their octa-core processor by the
end of this year so what do you guys
think do you guys think that the 9700 K
will come out before the end of this
year and how do you feel about rising
3rd generation do you think it'll
actually have 12 quart or 16 cores like
some rumors are suggesting make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time bye
[Music]